bonsoir et bienvenue pour le journal de
la rédaction le journal de téléfiles 78
sans plus attendre voici les titres du 7
8 l'actu de ce 11 décembre attrape le
quotidien de plusieurs locataires
victimes depuis plus de 3 semaines de
pannes électriques à répétition sans
chauffage en conflit avec le bailleur
social il sollicite aujourd'hui l'aide
des responsables politiques l'institut
d'étude culturelle internationale de
l'UVSQ remet ses premiers diplômés 50
ans en Yvelines c'est le premier
institut en France de ce type il a été
fondé en juillet dernier Véronique polis
a directrice adjointe viendra en plateau
nous le présenter et puis les travaux
sont terminés du musée de la toile de
Jouy le public peut accéder à nouveau au
site et redécouvrir les collections
abritées depuis 1991 dans le château à
19e siècle de l'églantine l'image du
jour c'est ce procès à Versailles le 8
janvier Cassandra Bellin sera donc fixé
sur son sort ainsi on a décidé le
tribunal correctionnaire de
correctionnel de Versailles ce mercredi
l'affaire Cassandra Bellens c'est
l'affaire d'un contrôle d'identité d'une
jeune femme intégralement voilée qui
tourne mal c'était à trappe en juillet
dernier une qui avait déclenché une
série d'émeutes dans la commune son mari
et Michael Kery a déjà été condamné à
trois mois de prison avec sursis pour
cette opposée à ce contrôle Cassandra
Belin était absente à l'audience le
parquet a requis 500 euros pour outrage
et 150 euros d'amende son avocat a aussi
déposé une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité au micro d'Anthony
Reich ce matin les avocats de la jeune
femme et des policiers on les écoute
est-ce que vous avez vu contrôler des
formes en burqa sur les Champs-Élysées
lorsqu'elles font leurs emplettes dans
des magasins de luxe non parce que c'est
peut-être des Saoudiennes ou des qatari
on prendrait l'accident diplomatique il
vaut mieux faire ça un trappe ou dans
des quartiers à Fort population
musulmane et un peu un peu plus sensible
puis je vais pas accepter je ne peux pas
accepter non plus qu'on
décrivent ce qui s'est passé par la
suite au commissariat comme une sorte de
de vie des morts-vivants enfin c'est pas
acceptable c'est le procès de gens qui
sous couvert d'un vernis de
revendication religieuse
soulève en réalité une argumentation qui
est une argumentation politique parce
que à partir d'un postulat religieux il
demande à ce que des règles qui sont les
règles communes de vie dans la
République c'est à dire la loi ne leur
soit pas applicable le mari de Madame
Belin lors de l'audience qui lui était
consacré en septembre il a dit que pour
lui la loi islamique était supérieure à
la loi française je crois que c'est un
résumé qui vaut mieux qu'un long
discours ce sont des gens qui utilisent
nos règles démocratiques pour essayer
d'obtenir des exceptions à l'application
de la loi en leur faveur lors du procès
du mari de Madame Belin il a dit très
benoîtement que pour lui et pour sa
femme la loi islamique était supérieure
à la loi française ce sont des gens qui
nous cherchent qui nous testent et il
faut que la République soit ferme sur
ses principes
depuis le 9 novembre une cinquantaine de
foyers rencontre des difficultés à
Trappes pour accéder à l'eau chaude et
également au chauffage avec le froid la
situation est forcément très
inconfortable des équipes techniques de
RDF ça fait sur place pour tenter de
dénouer ce problème mais leur ras-le-bol
des résidents et bien présent Olivier
Maniscalco et elodiemoine
les habitants du quartier Debussy à
Trappes face à des difficultés d'accès à
l'eau chaude depuis le 9 novembre c'est
une cinquantaine de foyers qui
rencontrent des problèmes d'électricité
empêchant le bon fonctionnement des
chauffe-eau la faute a des installations
électriques défectueuses qui font sans
cesse disjoncter les compteurs EDF et
forcément les ballons d'eau chaude
fonctionnent mal face à tous ces
problèmes les habitants sont à bout
alors d'aujourd'hui c'est je fais
chauffer de l'eau sur ma marmite et je
aux gants avec mon fils je peux même pas
lui faire prendre une douche les cheveux
c'est très rare que je lui lave je vais
chez ma mère qui habite à Bois-d'Arcy
qui a le confort ou chez ma belle-mère
il est en cours mais ici on peut rien
faire je fais avec avec ce qu'il y a
c'est à dire de l'eau froide et en plus
il gèle mais maintenant je veux dire on
peut plus tenir on en a ras-le-bol et on
se demande quand est-ce que l'on chaude
va être en rétabli
des travaux dans le quartier sont
actuellement en cours pour régler la
situation un groupe électrogène a été
mis en place et pour assurer la
pérennité de l'installation électrique
ERDF a décidé d'installer de nouveaux
câbles d'alimentation un mois de
chantier est nécessaire et la société
promet un retour à la normale dès le 17
décembre oui mais voilà certains ballons
d'eau chaude en fonctionné en marche
forcée les factures sont retrouvent plus
salées sur ce point
ERDF se fera rassurant
ERDF a déjà pris contact avec les
fournisseurs d'énergie ça sera neutre
pour les clients il n'y aura pas de
surcoût lié aux travaux sur le réseau
donc ça c'est c'est clair en attendant
que les choses ne reviennent à la
normale samedi matin les habitants du
quartier Debussy recevront la visite de
Guy Malandain le maire de Trappes
les candidats aux élections municipales
qui rentrent petit à petit en campagne à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Vivien gaz pour
le Parti socialiste vient de tenir une
réunion publique une réunion que ce
candidat d'opposition souhaitait d'un
genre nouveau
trois ateliers dans la commune ces
dernières semaines autour de la culture
la démocratie locale et la sécurité et
ce soir-là un forum ouvert Vivien gaz
que candidat socialiste aux municipales
veut faire campagnes autrement pour la
première fois à tête de liste à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il veut marquer
ses différences et aussi mettre fin à
son déficit de notoriété à la figure de
l'opposition sur la ville la conseillère
régionale Sandrine grandgambre lui ayant
passé la main l'an dernier pour partir
s'installer dans la commune voisine de
Trappes
du coup les gens de batterie lui aucune
image négatives et puis je sais pas je
bénéficie d'une bonne image plutôt
bienveillante de la de la population
c'est très intéressant et puis les gens
commencent à me reconnaître
on a été très présent comme on dit sur
le terrain entre guillemets c'est à dire
que on est allé rencontrer rencontrer
les inondins par des porte-à-portes en
allant frapper chez eux dans plusieurs
quartiers de la commune la tenue de ce
forum devrait permettre de peaufiner son
programme qui ne sera dévoilé qu'au
début de l'année prochaine il y sera
sans doute question de réunir
régulièrement le conseil local de
sécurité et de prévention de la
délinquance ou encore de délocaliser
ponctuellement la tenue du conseil
municipal quant à la composition de sa
liste il se réserve encore un peu de
temps et des discussions sont en cours
avec les différentes formations de
gauche même s'il semble acquis que le
partir radical gauche Europe Écologie
Les Verts et le Parti communiste feront
COSM commune avec les socialistes
l'institut d'étude culturelle et
internationale
ieci de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le premier
institut en France entièrement dédié aux
métiers de la culture et de la recherche
sur les questions culturelles et
interculturelles il a vu le jour au
printemps dernier sa directrice adjointe
et l'invité de cette édition du 7 8
lecture bonsoir bonsoir Véronique poly
que regroupe 7 institut pour être très
clair ce sont déjà trois départements de
formation de laboratoire de recherche
voilà trois départements de formation
histoire l'être et langue pour qui et
qu'on prend l'Institut comprend
actuellement plus de 1600 étudiants dans
ces trois départements il est le fruit
de la fusion de deux instituts ainsi
d'études culturelles et l'Institut des
langues et des études internationales le
but de cette fusion étant bien
évidemment de créer des synergies et des
passerelles entre toutes nos formations
1600 étudiants 70 enseignants chercheurs
vous venez de rappeler ces chiffres
l'objectif c'est ça c'est plus de ça
permet de d'échanger entre ces
différentes filières et d'éviter le
cloisonnement ne serait pour les
étudiants aussi pour les ouvrir à
d'autres horizons d'éviter le
cloisonnement il s'agit de enfin c'est
de plus en plus le cas nous essayons de
de créer de plus en plus de passerelles
entre nos formations niveau licence et
niveau master nous rentrons actuellement
dans une nouvelle phase de renégociation
avec le ministère de nos de nos
formations et ça va vraiment être
l'objet de notre travail
de que de créer de plus en plus de
passerelles
ça leur permet de changer de formation
cours de route aussi ça diffère un tout
petit peu le moment où on fait le choix
de sa finalité d'études
c'est-à-dire que nous nous créons des
formations qui comprennent des socles
communs et qui permettent à un moment du
du cursus de s'orienter vers un master
professionnel par exemple comme no
master archives ou nos Masters
administration culturelles publics et
privés
reçoivent le soutien de la Communauté
d'Agglomération alors ce qui concerne
l'étude des langues également ça permet
de désenclaver un petit peu ces études
des langues de l'insérer dans différents
programmes et de ne pas prendre que la
langue et aussi d'apprendre la culture
du pays par exemple voilà c'est à dire
qu'il s'agissait avec cette fusion des
deux instituts de désenclavé les langues
et de et de d'asseoir l'idée que
enseigner les langues à prendre une
langue c'est aussi apprendre des
cultures étrangères avec lesquels on
peut avoir à travailler par la suite et
cette institut a remis ses premiers
diplômes sous son eau officiel Dieu ci
c'était hier diplôme de licence de
Master également vous allez nous parler
des débouchés possibles on va déjà
écouter l'une des étudiantes nous dire
comment elle a vécu cette année ce
regroupement de formation
donc quand on fait de l'histoire on a
aussi fait de la socio on a aussi fait
de la go on a aussi fait de l'espagnol
et des langues et ça a permis d'avoir
des cours en commun par exemple en
histoire on avait des cours sur Charles
Quint que les licences espagnoles ont pu
suivre avec nous vu que Charles Quint a
été emprunt d'Espagne voilà ça a permis
un peu un melting pot de toutes les
licences c'est pas intéressant
en type de licence voilà ça permet aussi
aux étudiants de se rencontrer ne
serait-ce que ça ne serait-ce que ça
c'est déjà très
positif sa
chant que
des formats en double Valence soit des
formations qui dont les étudiants seront
issus de licences diverses notamment les
formations de Master qui pourront être
intéressantes pour des étudiants venant
par exemple d'histoire ou de langue voir
de l'être alors on voit les images de la
cérémonie hier ces étudiants aussi bien
en licence comme master pro qui ont reçu
leurs diplôme voilà ils étaient
forcément très contents quel déboucher
pour eux est-ce que ce sont des métiers
qui ensuite embauche tout à fait quel
type de métier pour être très précis
alors si l'on prend par exemple notre
master professionnel dit archives
100% des étudiants trouvent un emploi de
les
ce qui est plutôt une excellente
nouvelle
de même pour le Master administration
culturel public et privées mais pour le
reste de nos de nos formations nous
bénéficions des excellent taux de
réussite licence qui ont été publiées
l'année dernière en avril par le
ministère
6,4% de taux de réussite avec la
meilleure valeur ajoutée en France et
particulièrement allioti nous sommes
dans la quasi-totalité de nos formations
au-dessus de ces de ces excellentes de
la fondation de cet institut de d'études
autour de des métiers de la culture qui
a été fondé au printemps c'est aussi une
création qui vous permet aussi d'avoir
déjà plus de lisibilité ne serait-ce que
pour les intervenants extérieurs je dis
ça parce que vous travaillez beaucoup
avec le bassin local c'est ce que vous
m'expliquez avant cette émission tout à
fait nous avons des
l'Institut d'études culturelles et
internationale est fortement ancrée dans
le dans le territoire
et bénéficie dans ces formations
et dans sa recherche d'un fort appui de
la communauté d'agglomération nous
travaillons également beaucoup avec les
archives départementales avec la Maison
de la poésie avec le théâtre à la Maison
de la poésie par exemple
nous avons
avec la Maison de la Poésie nous avons
des prix en commun nous organisons des
événements un colloque la poésie or le
livre a donné lieu à une soirée dans le
cadre du festival la ville en poésie
donc les liens sont étroits ils sont
étroits également avec les
établissements scolaires du bassin des
Yvelines dans le cadre d'un plan
réussite licence 10 - 3 + 3 qui vise à
faciliter le passage de l'enseignement
secondaire à l'enseignement supérieur et
aussi accompagner les étudiants dans
leur cursus l'idée c'est d'enlever cette
image d'Épinal de l'étudiant qui reste
dans son livre toute la journée en
amphithéâtre avec ses cours magistraux
qui sont très très investis dans toutes
sortes d'activités culturelles mais
aussi associative voilà donc
le terme culture signifie vraiment
quelque chose pour nous c'est à dire que
la culture doit être vivante et elle
doit s'incarner dans des manifestations
qu'il s'agisse de psychologue
organisé par nos deux laboratoires de
recherche mais aussi des manifestations
d'une culture vivace associant le
territoire et nos étudiants le public
grand public peut aussi assister à ces
différents colloques qui sont organisés
nous avons un colloque de ces prochaines
semaines sur le portrait politique de
1914 à nos jours
et nous avons eu récemment un coloc sur
l'histoire l'écriture de l'histoire au
Moyen-Âge donc voyons vous voyez que
nous couvrons des périodes très très
vastes l'histoire qui intéresse toujours
le grand public qui a qu'à voir le
succès toutes ces émissions consacrées
différentes périodes historiques demain
jeudi autre sujet inter syndical
enseignant professeur qui va se
mobiliser pour dénoncer la gestion de
l'Université la situation financière
actuelle je vais rappeler qu'à l'heure
actuelle ce sont plutôt les économies
qui priment déficit de 4 millions
d'euros pour l'université de Versailles
en Yvelines c'était pas le sujet de
l'entretien de ce soir mais je voudrais
savoir quand même vous sur le terrain
comment vous percevez cette situation
est-ce que vous sentez ne serait-ce que
cette institut menacé par exemple pour
la suite ah non nous ne sommes
absolument pas menacés l'Institut n'est
pas menacé nos formations non plus
avec cette fusion nous avons déjà
beaucoup rationalisé nos structures et
nous notre gestion est saine et nous
avons bon espoir de ne pas bâtir de ces
difficultés que nous espérons le plus
passagère possible parce que justement
l'heure étant aux économies vous voulez
montrer que le modèle que vous avez mis
en place et plutôt efficace puisque ce
sont différents instituts qui sont
maintenant en un seul je ne légerai pas
en modèle il se trouve que
c'était il y avait une forme de logique
à rassembler un institut d'études
culturelles et un institut des langues
et des études internationales ça n'a
absolument pas valeur de modèle pour
l'ensemble de l'université il se trouve
que pour nous ça nous permet
effectivement
d'avoir plus de synergie et des
formations efficaces avec et nous permet
également une gestion saine merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau directrice adjointe
de lieuci donc cette institut d'études
culturelles et internationale merci
citoyenneté pour poursuivre ce 7 8
lecture nouveau conseil municipal des
jeunes à Bois-d'Arcy il prendra
officiellement ses fonctions le 17
décembre l'élection vient d'avoir lieu
dans l'un des collèges au collège Mozart
à Bois-d'Arcy
une urne débutant de vote une carte
d'électeurs tout comme les grands ils
n'ont pas l'âge de vote légale et
pourtant ces élèves du collège Mozart de
Bois-d'Arcy ont participé à l'élection
du conseil municipal des jeunes un cmglu
pour deux ans certains se présentent
pour la première fois avec déjà des
idées
pour parler aux jeunes des différents
activités qui sont proposées
aussi pouvoir
dire au CMJ les activités que les jeunes
voudraient faire ça peut être utile pour
certaines personnes les personnes
âgées qui peuvent pas aller chercher
leur livre tout seul bah on les aide à
les prendre ou les veufs et veuves vont
organiser des journées on est tous
ensemble et on s'amuse avec eux
ont déjà l'expérience du CMJ comme Maël
la sœur de Morgan elle se souvient des
actions menées en matière
d'environnement et de solidarité à
travailler pour le Burkina Faso donc on
récoltait de l'argent en faisant par
exemple le marché de Noël et donc on
apprend leur donne l'argent pour pour
qu'il fasse des écoles on a fait
plusieurs nettoyants notre ville donc on
pendant une matinée de trois heures on
se baladait dans la ville en récoltant
les déchets qui étaient par terre pour
cette session il n'y avait que 13
candidats pour 20 places mais peu
importe car la motivation est bien là
c'est l'occasion de donner la parole aux
jeunes en fait pour une fois souvent on
entend dire les jeunes ouais mais les
grands ils nous écoutent pas nous voilà
on a personne ne nous prend au sérieux
on est des enfants là au contraire on
leur donne l'occasion de s'exprimer donc
ils ont la possibilité de proposer des
projets et les présenter aux maires
surpris par les idées que eux peuvent
amener et sur le l'envie qui qui ont de
faire partager leur
envie de solidarité ou de citoyenneté
tous les sixième cinquième ils ont
jamais signé leur vie c'est leur la
première fois qu'on leur demande de
signer donc rien qu'à ce niveau là déjà
c'est intéressant après qu'on ait un
groupe qui s'investisse tant mieux mais
de rien que cette première partie c'est
déjà c'est déjà ça de gagner l'occasion
peut-être de créer des vocations
à voter sur les deux années qui viennent
de se terminer il y a certainement
en en a repéré quelques uns je pense que
oui oui il y a de la graine de il y a de
la graine d'élus pour demain mais il
faut qu'ils aient 18 ans n'est-ce pas le
nouveau conseil municipal des jeunes de
Bois-d'Arcy prendra ses fonctions
officiellement le 17 décembre
toujours autour de cette thématique de
la citoyenneté du civisme la préfecture
des Yvelines procède régulièrement à des
naturalisations désormais la procédure
n'est plus seulement symbolisée par un
simple décret papier les nouveaux
citoyens français doivent se soumettre à
des séances de sensibilisation à la
citoyenneté justement citoyenneté
française
avant d'obtenir leur décret de
naturalisation par le préfet cette
cinquantaine de candidats se voir appelé
les valeurs et institutions de la
République si tous connaissent le nom de
leur mère l'identité du président du
conseil général est encore parfois
incertaine le message de cette séance
être citoyen français ce n'est pas
seulement posséder une carte d'identité
chacun des droits et des devoirs
participer à la vie nationale et leur
dire voter la première étape et puis un
jour vous même
présentez-vous et pour être un élu de la
République
marocaine il est arrivé en France il y a
10 ans il y a effectué ses études
supérieures pour cette ingénieur
automobile de 28 ans la naturalisation
est une étape logique de sa vie sur le
territoire français
dès que c'était petit je me suis
intéressé à la maturation française et
donc voilà à l'époque de la Révolution
française toute les emblèmes de la
France le château de Versailles les
fresques c'est vraiment des choses qui
qui m'intéressaient depuis que j'étais
petit en venant ici en France voilà
c'est vraiment j'ai fait plein de
visites en des châteaux notamment
château de Versailles et donc voilà
c'est vraiment cette culture aussi qui
m'a attiré pour revenir ici en France en
2012 près de 2200 personnes ont été
naturalisées dans les Yvelines
cultures à présent après 6 mois de
chantier les nouveaux intérieurs
viennent d'être présentés le musée de la
toile de Jouy abrité depuis 1991 dans le
château de l'églantinais était fermé au
public pour des travaux depuis la
mi-juillet l'occasion de découvrir de
nouvelles collections dans savoir un peu
plus sur Oberkampf également le créateur
l'inventeur de cette toile de juillet un
personnage créateur et fin chef
d'entreprise Catherine zulato
elodiemoine
cette toile de coton rouge sur laquelle
sont imprimées des motifs qui racontent
le plus souvent des histoires cela vous
dit forcément quelque chose c'est la
fameuse toile de Jouy et comme son nom
l'indique elle a été créée et fabriquée
à jouer en Josas dans une manufacture
menée de main de maître par un homme
Oberkampf un musée lui est dédié sur le
site de l'ancienne usine qui a employé
entre 1760 et 1843 jusqu'à 1300
personnes au-delà de son travail c'est
l'homme qui étonne le plus
au barcampa par rapport aux autres c'est
que il a toujours été à la pointe des
inventions à la fois techniques
chimiques et artistique qui suivaient le
progrès du goût il est par exemple l'un
des tous premiers à blanchir ses toiles
avec le chlore c'est un coloriste
c'était un graveur il savait graver ses
planches c'était un dessinateur il a
créé ses premiers modèles tout seul un
chef d'entreprise un entrepreneur
vraiment y cumulé toutes les qualités
c'est grâce à ça qu'il a fait de son
entreprise la troisième entreprise en
fait de France au début de son aventure
oberkan fournit la cour royale c'est
pour cela qu'il s'installe près de
Versailles dans ses ateliers il y
développe la productivité avant l'heure
même dans l'organisation physique de la
manufacture on le voit bien il a le
grand bâtiment 210 mètres de long qui
fait construire dans les années 1790
pour les imprimeurs avec des grandes
fenêtres pour pouvoir mettre les tables
d'impression les plus longues possibles
il y a un bâtiment qui est pour la
blanchisserie un bâtiment qui est pour
la teinture donc tout est organisé pour
ne pas perdre de temps dans la
fabrication des toiles
Etienne Mallet est l'un des descendants
d'ober camp c'était son 4e arriere
grand-père et de cette illustre ancêtre
il retient la modernité et le sens
social c'est quelqu'un qui a un sens
social très développé et il
faut savoir que il a quelque part
inventé la sécurité sociale avant
qu'elle existe quand il y a eu les
assignats et l'inflation épouvantable y
payait en argent réel et non pas en
assigna ses ouvriers il faisait en sorte
que les ouvriers puissent épargner et
devenus être propriétaire de leur
logement il voulait toujours être à la
pointe et donc il inventait des moyens
si vous voulez pour effectivement
fabriquer mieux plus vite
sans d'ailleurs diminuer le nombre
d'ouvriers dans les pires périodes il
s'arrangeait pour que personne ne soit
pas soit licencié
ici dans le musée de la toile de Jouy
est présenté une cinquantaine de toiles
6000 sont en réserve c'est dire si les
collections seront renouvelées
régulièrement les 15000 visiteurs
annuels pourront découvrir les plus
connus comme le ballon de Gonesse qui a
donné à oberkamp ses lettres de noblesse
ou encore d'autres plus insolites comme
ces coquesigrues on lit sur ses toiles
comme sur des bandes dessinées la
manufacture a cessé de produire en 1843
on peut toujours fabriquer de la toile
de jouets en s'inspirant des motifs mais
attention aux contrefaçon car le nom n'a
pas été déposé Oberkampf n'avait pas
pensé à tout
et si vous n'étiez pas avec nous au
début de cette édition je vous propose
de revoir l'image du jour c'est ce
procès à Versailles le 8 janvier
Cassandra Belin sera fixé sur son sort
si on a décidé de tribunal correctionnel
de Versailles ce mercredi la faire
Cassandra Belin c'est l'affaire d'un
contrôle d'identité d'une jeune femme
intégralement voilée qui tourne mal
c'était à Trappes en juillet dernier une
affaire qui avait déclenché une série
d'émeutes dans la commune son mari
Michael kieri que l'on voit à l'image a
déjà été condamné précédemment à trois
mois de prison avec sursis pour cette
opposé à ce contrôle de son épouse
Cassandra Belin était-elle absente ce
matin à l'audience le parquet a requis
500 euros pour outrage et 150 euros
d'amende son avocat a également déposé
une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité le journal revient
demain jeudi 18h en direct comme
toujours nous parlerons notamment de la
grève à la SNCF les cheminots qui
contestent la réforme ferroviaire qui
s'engage les syndicats craignent un
éclatement du système ferroviaire et
donc un pas vers la privatisation le
mouvement s'annonce plutôt suivi avec
seulement la moitié des trains en
circulation à titre d'exemple si
Transilien sur 10 en Île-de-France ce
mercredi soir sur téléfilm vous avez
rendez-vous avec Aurélia Debussy pour
kiosque le magazine culturel 2 la
rédaction concernant le journal vous
pouvez laisser vos commentaires sur les
réseaux sociaux sur Twitter avec le
hashtag 7 8actu bonne soirée à demain